Good morning Hank; it's Tuesday.
I am in North Carolina for the Paper Towns
movie.
I actually slept- [alarm chirps quickly] That.
That is the reason that I slept last night
in director Jake Schreier's apartment.
So even though we don't start filming for
a week, I've already slept with the director
and had pizza with Cara Delevingne.
I'm getting to know everyone pretty intimately.
Okay [beep] Aughhhh!
Okay we have to go to a meeting and plus that's
happening every twenty seconds, so walk with
me.
John: This is Issac Klausner the executive
producer of Paper Towns.
And executive producer of The Fault in Our
Stars.
Isaac: Hello.
John: And this is Jake Schreier who is directing
the movie.
Jake: Hello.
John: That is the schedule for the movie.
I'm not gonna get any closer to it because
I can't show it to you, but that is it.
The whole movie is on that wall.
So I just sat in on a meeting about, like,
camera angles and shots, and there was a lot
of language that I don't even know what the
words mean.
Which is weird, Hank, because I am also in
the movie making business.
You know like a, like these movies.
So Hank, I really liked your video about the
octothorpe.
There's just something really compelling about
people including a symbol in their technology
even though they don't know what it's for
yet.
Lone coat hanger.
Hello there.
You know what, coat hanger, I know that you're
alone in the world right now, and I know it's
not easy, but I want you to know that one
day you are gonna hold some clothes.
Right, but about octothorpes: there's this
extraordinary generosity involved in creating
something and leaving room inside of it for
other people to create.
John: Now admittedly most of what we did was
create hashtags, but still.
Oh.
Lacey Pemberton's here.
Halston: Do we look into the camera?
John: Yeah.
Halston: Oh hi guys.
John: It's first person.
This is Halston Sage.
Halston: Hi!
John: Who plays Lacey in the movie.
Have you read the book?
Halston: I love the book.
John: Thank you.
Halston: I even highlighted it.
John: She has to say that.
She's obligated to.
Halston: I have the cutest fifteen year old
sister; her name's Kate.
She's actually a huge fan.
John: Is she really?
Halston: Yeah, yeah!
So this is-
John: Hi Kate!
Halston: Hi Kate!
John: This is Jaz Sinclair who plays Angela
in the movie.
Jaz: Hi!
John: So Jaz is a fan of the book and, um,
was really excited to audition, and she just
killed it.
So.
Now she's Angela.
How tall are you?
5'4"?
Jaz: 5'5".
How tall are you?
John: 6'1".
But don't tell my brother that because he's
also 6'1" and he's about an inch taller than
I am.
Jaz: So you're NOT 6'1".
John: And this is Justice Smith who plays
Radar in the movie.
Justice: Hello.
I'm not an a MMA fighter though.
John: Right there's a guy; we'll put a he's
gonna be right over- ugh I'm so bad at that.
Justice: Yeah he'll be right.
John: But he is a 6'9" 44 year old MMA fighter,
which I don't, just didn't feel was right
for the part.
Justice: Right.
John: Yeah.
Justice: But a lot of people were upset.
A lot of people were mad about it.
John: Yeah.
Yeah, no, we cast Justice instead.
I like your sweater today!
Justice: Thanks.
I almost got a hundred bucks for it!
John: It's pretty nice!
Justice: I almost got ... from Austin, he
almost paid me a hundred bucks.
John: The guy who's playing Ben.
Justice: Yeah.
Ben almost paid me a hundred bucks for this
sweater.
John: Ahhhh!
Justice: What's up bud?
John: How are you?
Justice: I'm good.
How are you?
John: I'm good.
You gonna go get your hair cut?
Justice: Yeah.
John: I just found out that Justice is a big
Grace Helbig fan.
Justice: Yeah, I love her.
John: Hank.
Hank!
I'm, I'm in the room with the black Santas.
This is part of Saul's house from Homeland.
It's not going to be in our movie.
That stuff will though, on the other side
of that, but I can't show it to you because
that would be cheating.
So Hank, we're going to the read-through now
where we're gonna all hear the cast read the
script for the first time.
Stop photobombing!
It's very exciting.
And then I think I get to go to bed.
Mike: Hi, Hank!
John: You guys did a good job with the script.
Scott: Thank you that means, uh ...
Mike: Oh!
Scott: ... a lot coming from somebody who's
read the book.
John: Okay, the table read went great, but
I am exhausted.
But I'm so excited about the Paper Towns movie
and so grateful to everyone who's coming together
to make it.
Long-time nerdfighters will know that I've
had some slightly tortured experiences with
Paper Towns in Hollywood over the years.
But now, everything's going so well, and I'm
just so excited.
So thank you to everyone who had read the
book and supported it.
Hank, thank you!
I was watching your video, and it occurred
to me that genuinely, of all the people I
know, you are the best at building things
that have octothorpes inside of them.
So thanks for all the octothorpes.
I'll see you on Friday.